tengo esta reacción aquí donde tengo un
molde metano y lo hago reaccionar con
dos de oxígeno gaseoso y eso me produce
el co2 y agua verdad y lo que quiero
responder en este vídeo es cuando esta
reacción es espontánea y aprendimos en
el último vídeo que para responder esto
tenemos que volvernos hacia la energía
libre de gips ver el cambio en la
energía libre de jeeps ok y esto es
igual al cambio en la ent al pia
- menos la temperatura la cual está
ocurriendo por el cambio en la entropía
y si esto es menor que cero entonces es
una reacción espontánea ok
así que les les dio un poquito de donde
iniciar calculado el cambio en la
antártida para esta reacción que está
justo aquí y sabemos cómo hacer esto
hemos hecho esto algunos vídeos atrás
simplemente tomamos el calor de
formación de cada uno de los productos y
por ejemplo para el agua lo
multiplicamos por dos porque tiene dos
moles así que tenemos este calor de
formación y le restamos el calor de
formación de los reactivos y por
supuesto el calor de formación del o2 es
cero así que ni siquiera pinta por
ejemplo entonces obtenemos que es menos
80 800 90.3 kilo jules eso nos dice que
es una reacción exotérmica que el lado
derecho en el lado derecho se libera
energía así que alguna energía debió
haber salido podríamos ponerlo incluso
aquí más de energía va a ser liberada
así que por eso es exotérmica ahora
nuestra pregunta es es espontánea así
que para figurar esto vamos a
a ver quién es delta ese delta ese el
cambio la entropía y para determinar del
tae se
ya he mirado en la web la la entropía
estándar molar ok
déjenme escribirlo aquí con otro color
ok esto es simplemente la anotación no
lleva delta simplemente es la s déjenme
inscribirlo aquí ok le ponemos un
simbolito 0 más o menos la entropía
molar estándar así que a temperatura de
standard eso es 298 grados kelvin no no
tiene uno que decir grados verdad solo
298 kelvin ok a esta temperatura que es
esencialmente 25 grados celsius que es
de una de cualquier habitación así que
esta entropía staandard el metano ok a
una temperatura de un cuarto es igual
este número 186 jules por kelvin por mol
sobre kelvin por mol más bien así que si
tengo un molde meta no tengo 186 yus por
o bueno sobre que elvin fórmula por mol
y si tengo tres moles por ejemplo
debería multiplicar el soporte es así
que el cambio total en la entropía de
esta reacción es el total
del total de las propias estándar del
producto menos los de los reactivos
justo como lo hicimos con la en tal pie
así que eso va a ser igual a 213 puntos
y más tengo dos moles de agua así que
tengo que multiplicar por 2 es 2 x
prácticamente 70 verdad así que vamos a
dejarlo así más 272 por 70 y luego le
restó el de los reactivos que es le
restó la entropía de los reactivos así
que vamos a restarle la entropía de un
molde metano que es 186 y también vamos
a quitar dos veces la entropía del
oxígeno que es 205 así que simplemente
ya tenemos estos números ahí medio
echándole un ojo el lado derecho va a
ser mucho más grande que el lado
izquierdo y por lo tanto intuyo que va a
ser negativo porque por ejemplo él por
ejemplo la entropía del agua es mucho
menor que el del oxígeno así que debido
a esto no sé quizás es porque el el
líquido no tiene tantas posibilidades de
tener ciertos ciertos estados así que
tiene una entropía mucho menor así que
más o menos al primer ojo puedo ver que
el la entropía de los productos es va a
ser mucho menor que el de los reactivos
pero vamos a confirmar eso
que tenemos 213 203 21 3.6
ok es 2 por 70 que 140 así que vamos a
sumarle 140 y eso es 350 y 3.6
53.6 y de esto vamos a restarle vamos a
restarle 186 más 202 por 205 que es
2 por 205 nos da en total 500 96
y eso por supuesto vamos a ver menos 596
y le agregamos 35 3.6 tenemos menos 240
y 2.4
así que esto es igual a 24 2.4 news
sobre kelvin y esto es nuestra delta
estoy aquí me falta ponerle el menos así
que perdemos toda esa entropía y estas
unidades pueden no tener mucho sentido
ahorita en este momento pero bueno
esencialmente nos está diciendo que esto
se está volviendo más ordenado tenemos
tres moléculas separadas digamos uno
aquí y dos de oxígeno y después tenemos
tres moléculas de nuevo pero el agua
ahora es líquida así que eso hace
sentido para mí de que pierda entropía
hay menos estados para el líquido
especialmente que puede tener así que
vamos a ver si estas reacciones
espontáneas y ahora nuestra delta que
delta que es igual a delta h que ya
vimos que es menos 8 890 punto 3
- 890 menos la temperatura pero estamos
suponiendo que estamos a temperaturas
del cuarto que es 298 kelvin ok 298
kelvin grados kelvin que son 25 grados
celsius por el cambio en la entropía
aunque ahora esto va a ser menos 240 y
2.4 pero si somos muy muy cuidadosos
esto aquí está en kilo jules y este
fiesta en jules así que si queremos
escribir todo esto en kilo jules debido
a que hay que hay que hacer la
conversión así que esto es punto 242
kilos jules kilo jules por sobre que el
min
keys déjenme quitar ese punto 4 y
dejarle el kilo jules así que nuestra
energía libre de jeeps de aquí va a ser
menos ochocientos noventa kilos jules
menos 298 en realidad tenemos más verdad
y este este término de la derecha va a
ser 298 por una fracción es
esencialmente es menos que 298 y con el
890 se ve a primera vista que esto en
total va a ser negativo porque hoy menos
890 le va a ganar por mucho al otro
término pero bueno vamos a ver vamos a
ver qué es lo que nos da realmente así
que tenemos 123 ok ese es nuestro cambio
la entropía verdad por 298 es menos 72
eso es menos esto en realidad se
convierte en 72 puntos 2
así que este es el término de la
entropía a temperatura estándar y eso es
y esto de la izquierda es la entalpía el
camión lenta al pie así que ya podemos
ver que el camión en tal pie es mucho
más más negativo digamos o más grande
que el cambio la entropía y por lo tanto
este término va a ganar incluso si
perdemos entropía en esta reacción
esto libera tanta energía que va a ser
espontánea y esto es definitivamente
menor que cero así que va a ser
espontánea una reacción responsable
espontánea así que como puedes ver la
energía libre de jeeps no fue tan
difícil de calcular sólo hay que
encontrar estos valores y que pueden
estar dados por datos que se encuentran
en internet verdad por ejemplo el delta
h ya sabemos cómo hacerlo es el calor de
formación de los productos menos el de
los reactivos multiplicando por sus
respectivos coeficientes y después hay
que encontrar el cambio la entropía y
hacemos exactamente lo mismo con la
entropía molar estándar de los productos
multiplicado por sus coeficientes y le
restamos el de los reactivos ok y esta
revista nos va a dar esencialmente la
energía libre
que en este caso fue negativa ahora
puedes imaginar una situación donde
estás a mucha mayor temperatura digamos
la superficie del sol o algo así
ok en vez de 298 a lo mejor podría estar
2000 grados kelvin o 4000 entonces todas
estas cosas pueden volverse interesantes
si puedes imaginarte pues no sé tener
40.000 grados kelvin de temperatura
entonces todo este término entropía va a
importar mucho más así que este término
va a ser positivo y quizás le gane al
del cambio de la intel pía verdad y ya
no sea espontánea a otra forma de
pensarlo es que una reacción que genera
calor ok que libera al calor el calor
liberado no importa mucho cuando estás a
una temperatura ambiente debido a la
energía cinética si la temperatura era
suficientemente alta entonces puede no
ser espontánea ok pero de cualquier
forma eso lo quiero sólo quería hacer
estos cálculos para mostrarles que no
hay nada abstracto todo lo encontramos
en internet y podemos decir si algo es
espontáneo